[Music]
we unleashed something powerful
PAHs we Pat this together there is
another person I can take maybe I'm
doing it wrong you have no idea what I'm
capable just wanted to give me a hug
wish me luck really
watch this
sorry I'm messing around
which I had a suit
even with like mineral powers or maybe
even just the soup with no powers no so
how long have you been ant-man again no
uh I just sort of happened it's like bad
guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch her
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
that walks two walls of stuff
slowly tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who believe that in your hour of need
you would turn the house happy because
we robbed you do you remember that's us
feeling chef you grab this video
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you to
our flesh comparing sizes 65
[Music]